My name's Miles Morales for the
past year I've been this diamond
as one and only Spider-Man
and things are going great
and I keep getting strong miles we gotta
talk oh Gwen want to get out of here
unbelievable so vitamin there's an elite
crew with all the best spider people in it
that's Miguel O'Hara she's like a ninja
vampire the whole thing was his idea we're
trying to keep the Multiverse from collapsing
so what's a guy gotta do to join this spider
team you can never be part of this come on
go easy on the kid he had a terrible day
you got a kid oh here we go I'll take
it from here miles being Spider-Man is
a sacrifice hands in the air that's the job
so we're just supposed to let people die you
have a choice between saving one person and
saving every world I can do both man oh always
Ben most of us wouldn't be here stop him now
Stop him. Now!
Miguel, this isn't what we're talking about is
it what we talked about we are supposed
We are. Everyone keeps telling me how
my story I'm gonna do my own thing
All stations, stop Spider-Man.
Hello Spider-Man, hi hi. Not you I think he means me.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my brand new Spider-Man Across the Spider-Verse
trailer there's a bunch of new footage Easter
eggs they also showed off a much longer scene
at Cinemacon so I'll break that down during
this too also explain what their plan is for
having the characters show up in Avengers Secret
Wars because it has to do with the part 3 movie
Spider-man beyond the spider verse in the way
that part one was Into the spider-verse Now
part two is across the spider-verse part 3 which
is releasing next year will be called beyond the
spiderverse so I think when they say beyond the
spider verse that's also a tongue-in-cheek way of
saying that the characters will appear in live
action during Avengers Secret Wars there'll be
a bunch more footage for this really soon too be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos and really
cool news doing a special giveaway because it is
also Star Wars week in addition to Guardians of
the Galaxy coming out so the Star Wars people
asked to sponsor one of my giveaways Amazon
and Star Wars they just released these new limited
edition Star Wars Echo dots stands there are three
of them you can pre-order right now a stormtrooper
a Darth Vader helmet and the man delorean's helmet
I'll be giving all three of these away to random
commenters on this video the echo dots work with
Amazon's Alexa system answering your questions
or providing instructions or recommendations or
helping you stay organized you put the echo dots
inside the different helmets and they give off
these cool lighting effects just based on what
you're asking them or the way you interact with
the echo dots really good example is asking them
Star Wars questions Alexa begin my Jedi lessons
as Yoda taught us the best master is a cute
little puppet you can make your own with an
old sock and googly eyes if the sock looks and
smells like it's 900 years old that's even better
to continue your training just ask me for
another Jedi lesson Alexa how do you build
a lightsaber according to wikiHow here's how
to make a lightsaber using everyday items
step one find a torch flashlight that emits a
white light the brighter the better if it's too
weak it may not do the trick most flashlights
you find in your bottom kitchen drawer will do
the job just fine if you find a flashlight slash
torch that's too dim try replacing the batteries
you can ask them all kinds of questions they don't
have to just be Star Wars questions and you don't
have to add batteries to the different Star Wars
helmets you only have to plug in the Echo dots
and Amazon's Alexa system works to an app on
your phone you can pre-order them right now
I'll include a link on screen here and down in the
description below so be sure to check it out but
at the beginning of the new trailer Miles Morales
Recaps what's happened to him since the events of
the last movie it's been a little while that's
why he's a little bit bigger a little bit older
his powers have gotten a little bit stronger as
you see during the trailer like he's able to evade
the spider army or whatever you want to call it
spider Society if you actually signed up for the
special text that they're doing for this movie
they call it spider Society I've also heard the
directors call it the spider force and if we're
talking about spider vs Easter eggs like in the
comics it's called the spider army they had the
funny scene of him riding the subway while he's
wearing his Spider-Man costume and bringing the
food to the party that he's going to be laid out
that his parents yell at him for in the previous
trailers like you were supposed to be here on
time if you look around this scene too you can see
that everybody else is just totally unimpressed by
him being in the Spider-Man costume like they
probably seen him on the news and they're just
like yeah whatever another superhero who cares
I lived in New York City for a couple years and
everybody was generally like this on subways like
the weirdest people would get on the Subways crazy
things would happen and unless somebody lit your
clothes on fire people just would not turn their
heads to care the reason is spidey sense goes
off is because he senses something crazy is
about to happen and he wants to stop it but he's
stuck with all these people and the food that he
doesn't want to spill before he gets to the party
which you could think of is a funny reference to
Spider-Man 2 with Toby Maguire Spider-Man and the
pizza that he had to deliver while also trying to
be Spider-Man and saving people oh he stole that
guy's pizzas they actually put a bunch of Toby
McGuire Spider-Man Andrew Garfield Spider-Man and
Tom Holland MCU Spider-Man footage in the last big
trailer or one of the international versions
of the last big trailer the reason why they
did that I think is because of their larger plan
to move these spider-verse characters into live
action for Avengers Secret Wars also the idea that
they're going to have a cameo seen from at least
Tom Holland Spider-Man in the movie like they're
slowly tying the spider-verse characters to the
other versions of live-action Spider-Man way back
when they were making the first movie Tom Holland
actually said that there have been talks for him
to cameo in the first movie and he was going to
have a moment with Miles Morales talking about
other Spider-Man that were out there like wow
there's a Multiverse of Spider-Man but the problem
was they had so much Spider-Man going on in live
action with Avengers Infinity War Avengers end
game and all the other Spider-Man movies like
Spider-Man far from home there just wasn't room
in the schedule for him to actually do stuff
for that first into the spider-verse movie The
Producers also were talking about putting all
the versions of live action in Spider-Man in the
movie at some point too like of course there were
live action elements in the first movie anyway
this time though right now the report is the
plan is in beyond the spider verse like the part
3 movie that releases next year is meant to be the
escalation from the events of this movie and move
the characters into live action but they didn't
say how many of the spider-verse characters will
be in live action right now I'm just assuming that
it's at least Miles Morales and spider Gwen that
would be funny because Haley Steinfeld also plays
the live-action version of Kate Bishop Hawkeye so
we'll see how they pull that off it may be a small
chance for Peter B Parker in some background other
versions of Spider-Man but if they had a bunch of
other versions it'd probably be CG small and in
the background kind of like these scenes here
that you see in this movie where you don't see
them take their Mass off they just see a bunch
of different versions of them in the background
speaking of taking your mask off they actually
revealed that Andy Samberg is going to be playing
the Ben Reilly Scarlet Spider they actually get a
big cheer for it at cinemacon well I heard about
the new Spider-Man movie figured I would odd dish
maybe catch that part in my way web aren't you
just redoing the same monologue that Kirsten
Dunst did like 10 years ago uh yeah aren't you
just redoing the exact same Spider-Man movie from
10 years ago they said there was also a couple
surprise cameos that they didn't tell the actors
about either and I think those are meant to be
the Tom Holland Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
cameos there's a slightly different version of
spider-gwen showing him the Multiverse bass and
them talking about what their actual mission
is like Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 brought
us together to try to keep the Multiverse from
collapsing because of all the different things
that all these different versions of Spider-Man
have been doing which is when he makes the other
Tom Holland Spider-Man no way home reference
about the nerd from Earth 19999 in Doctor
Strange because they messed the Multiverse up so
bad with the spell and as cool as that is that's
not the only thing that caused problems with the
Multiverse like there are a bunch of incursions
that they tease during Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Madness despite her Army that Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 2099 puts together is also dealing
with all of those other problems too from other
realities when spider Gwen says that he's kind
of like a Spider-Man cross with a Vampire that's
just because of the way Miguel O'Hara's Spider-Man
Powers work compared to other normal versions of
Spider-Man is mostly reference to his fangs and
his talents so he does have fangs naturally the
grud of his mouth and he can't retract them they
used to create a non-fatal sedative that paralyzes
villains that he fights the other big difference
are the talons on his fingers and his feet that
he uses to stick to walls and surfaces instead of
the hairs like normal versions of Spider-Man so
it just makes him seem like a vampire version of
Spider-Man even though that's not what's actually
happening like he is biting people like a vampire
but he's mostly doing it to paralyze them there's
a much longer scene of this new character spider
bite who's glitching around the control room she's
meant to be based on a version that debuted during
spider-geden more recently and she's from a world
kind of like the world of Ready Player one where
most people spend all their time in a virtual
environment as avatars she decided to become a
vigilante fight crime and then got recruited into
the spider Army to fight the inheritors during
the comic book version of the story there's a
much longer version of that funny scene where
Spider-Man 2099 calls all the other versions
in the spider Army to action everyone capture
Spider-Man as they all look at their wrist devices
that he gave them we had a couple new scenes of
Miles Morales using his powers like the bomb of
webbing that he throws Spider-Man 29-9 the funny
thing even though they're hyping this movie is
Miles Morales versus all the other versions of
Spider-Man like Miles Morales versus the spider
Army technically the spot is supposed to be the
main villain of the movie The longer scene that
they showed off of the movie is cinemacon is
just hyping up the whole connection to Avengers
Kang Dynasty in the incursions in them trying
to prevent universes from colliding with each
other which is what an incursion is like I said
just everything points to them trying to tie this
spider-verse continuity in these characters into
the live-action Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
secret War stuff I've already talked about most
of the major other versions of Spider-Man in my
previous trailer videos so I'll link those Below
in the description but if you spotted any other
Easter eggs or references in the trail that I
didn't talk about in the video just write them
below in the comments and I'll name a giveaway
winner for that special giveaway in the next
couple of videos Everyone click here for all my
Guardians of the Galaxy three videos of the link
as soon as I finish my post credit scene video and
click here for my brand new Dune part 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!